[Music]
go with there wait for me I've been
shooting since I was about five years
old it's been in my family and in my
blood or as long as I can remember plus
I just got tired of paying full price
for guns figured that out and turned
into a business I do come from the
modeling industry where there's tons and
tons of rejections but with flowers it's
always accepted really pretty how you
like that that's beautiful yes sir
I feel like people find it hard to talk
about money because it's kind of like a
little secret and you don't want people
to judge you based on how much you make
[Music]
my name is Jonathan solomon co-founder
of red star firearms we sell firearms we
do trainings range classes basic classes
it has been as low as $25,000 for the
year when we first started off to evolve
75 to 80 thousand dollars a year now
growing up where I did grow up it was
very heavily gang infested personally
firearms has kept me out of trouble it
turned into a sport and a hobby that I
like to share with my friends and family
how you doing get thirty on two please
oh so cold
[Music]
I'm Hanna Jo I am a studio floral
boutique owner and my company's name is
Hana by Hannah all I did was create a
page just to post flower arrangements on
and then it just became something owning
my own business
I've never even imagined myself doing
that so all the Lux flowers are all done
I like to handpick my Lux flowers I
would say for weddings on average my
clients have been spending around four
to five thousand dollars sometimes I'll
have one event sometimes I'll have
multiple events in a week it just
fluctuates like crazy
[Music]
I know it's like a trend right now is it
breast
pink I'm been done for flower shop so
how many people do you have signed up
for today about 11 for one course eight
for another we'll see sometimes we get
some last-minute signups literally
last-minute they'll come in the morning
of thousand rounds are nine priests 1:15
anyone you right well that was two
longer for the Rachel and fifty for the
running of small business is not easy at
all this was a major leap 85 and 90
hours a week if not a little bit more
but it's been fun gotta love them fast I
have to go pick up my dog and drop him
off at the groomers and then we'll go to
the studio does your career interfere
with your personally I've been making an
effort and trying to finish things by
dinnertime so at least I could go home
and have dinner with my husband
occasionally I'll have long days like
yesterday I was working till 1:00 a.m.
[Applause]
people think I just play with flowers
all day and don't see all the buckets
you have to clean my hand isn't
everything like every little aspect the
administrative stuff to the managing
have to spread so fin physically I'm
exhausted
but mentally I've been so happy I'm Way
more fulfilled creatively doing this
profession versus modeling because
modeling you're told what to do you
don't really have room for creativity
they do your hair makeup outfit you're
basically a mannequin with your
peripherals come on lend that touch that
long time good a lot of good 80% of is
my wife and I financed out of pocket
we're African American selling firearms
so getting loans from banks were
non-existent we still can't get a loan
from the bank
[Music]
I don't say racist groups but groups
that don't necessarily like firearms and
they don't necessarily like black
selling firearms we've had things
scribbled onto the window of the store
we've gotten death threats for your
phone it's been pretty difficult but we
stay resilient and you're gonna keep
pushing forward it's not done yet
but progress it's the greatest feeling
when they thank you and like tell you
how much your work really meant to them
I don't think I've met a person where
you give them flowers and they're like
you it's always accepted it's a big huge
stigma with firearms in the state of
California which should not be that way
firearms are a tool period yes we do
need gun laws yes it's not that the laws
need to be changed anymore people have
to know what's right and wrong
[Music]
getting light strikes it pretty yeah the
flowers that really stand out to me are
the very unique ones or like the ones
that not a lot of people like I think
everything can be interpreted as
beautiful you just need to fix your eyes
and the way you think you know it
represents peace for me as stressful as
it is I think it's the most therapeutic
when I'm just by myself designing when
you think of guns what words come to
mind tools to protect you and your
family as well as have fun with when
done properly
all right let's get out of here how much
do you make on a day like today with two
classes I'd be about $1,800 for today
besides the range fees to rent the range
we have insurance fees things of that
nature we are done for the day we'll
start it all over again tomorrow
okay so we're rolling can you break down
your expenses from the day we film with
supply cost all together I spent around
like I don't believe money defines
people money does definitely help folks
live a better life open up doors for
different opportunities I don't need to
be doing like the most extravagant
weddings you see in magazines I don't
know I'm just going as it happens we do
have kids and we want to try to set up
some type of generational wealth system
so when they get to be our age they're
not struggling like my wife and idea
when we were growing up as long as I'm
not negative I think I'm good
[Music]
that was a really cool contrast yeah
kinda like that the bat and guns and
roses thanks for watching that video we
always make things that try to bridge
people together show different
perspectives just go a little bit deeper
with humanity we also love featuring a
diversity of talent and people you've
got ideas for new episodes let us know
in the comments below and if you'd like
to be a part of one also make sure you
fill out the has some sheet below as
always like subscribe follow us on
Instagram thank you for watching I will
see you next time
[Music]